hello there today we'll look at
excite cross covariance image
transformers
by facebook ai indriya and sobon
university so in this paper the authors
propose
a kind of a transpose of an attention
mechanism so instead of the attention
working across
tokens and tokens attending to
other tokens now it is the
features or the channels attending to
other channels and in a matter
across the entire sequence that you
input
this means there is no longer a
quadratic complexity
in the length of the input sequence and
this supposedly works particularly well
for
image data so these are
akin to the vision transformers that
work on
patches in patched images and
they reach comparable good performance
on
things like imagenet classification
self-supervised learning but also
dense prediction like uh segmentation
and so on
so we're going to look into this paper
it is
it is kind of weird to how to think
about this
um so the idea is pretty simple but i
think it's kind of weird
and it the question is to me a little
bit
uh can this still be called a
transformer
in the way that it operates because as
it seems to me
after reading the paper and i think they
also
mentioned this during the paper it is
more like
a convnet honestly that just kind of
um has one dynamic part in it so one of
the convolutions
is a dynamic convolutions but we'll see
and uh you know this could be a good
architecture
for future image for future image
processing so here they say
let me grab my yellow following
tremendous success in nlp
transformers have recently shown much
promise for computer vision
okay so the self-attention operation
underlying transformers yields global
interactions between
all tokens ie words or image patches and
enables flexible modeling of image data
beyond the local
interactions of convolutions this
flexibility comes with a quadratic
complexity and time
and memory hindering application to long
sequences
and high resolution images so this is
the the problem
transformers good attention mechanism
powerful
however there is a quadratic complexity
in time and memory
in terms of the sequence length and
that's why we can't
apply it to long sequences or high
resolution images
they say we propose a transposed version
of self-attention
that operates across feature channels
rather than tokens okay
where the interactions are based on the
cross-covariance matrix between keys and
queries
the resulting cross-covariance attention
has linear complexity in the number of
tokens allows efficient processing of
high resolution images
yada yada okay so and then they propose
a
an entire architecture built upon the
xca the cross covariance attention which
they call
excite so that's the cross covariance
image
transformer it says it combines the
accuracy of conventional transformers
with the sealability of convolutional
architectures sorry
scalability we
validate the effectiveness by reporting
excellent results on multiple benchmarks
including self-supervised image
classification
on imagenet object detection instant
segmentation yadda yadda they're super
good
okay so what is this
new kind of attention this is the main
graphic in the paper and on the left you
can see
how the whole attention looks so this
would be the whole model
is consistent of these excite layers so
you'd have sort of
input tokens down here and then you have
l of these excite
blocks and at the end you'd have
whatever a classification layer
or a segmentation layer or something
like this but in
in our case this here is what would be
a self attention but followed by a feed
forward network
and you can see that the cell it's
essentially the same the feed forward
network is still here
but the self-attention block has been
replaced by
these two blocks and the bottom one is
this cross
covariance attention which does
attention
pretty much like you're used to there's
a there's a tiny difference i said the
idea here is
pretty simple uh in the in the
mathematical way
it's just a bit weird to think about it
so on the top
you have the classic self-attention that
is used throughout transformers
currently and on the bottom you have
this new proposed cross covariance
attention
and you might notice that the only thing
that
is different if you look at the at the
pictures is that the
green and the orange matrix here are
skipped so for that
we dive a little bit into what attention
does
regular usually so i think i've drawn
this picture
about a thousand times but um forgive me
if i do it one more time okay
so um every we have let's say we have
a series of tokens like this one here
and this can be
word word embeddings in language but
this can be image
patches in images so the way vision
transformers work
is it's prohibitively large to process
each pixel
individually so what they do is they
take the image and they
put it into patches and now each patch
becomes
sort of one of these tokens okay
as opposed to convolutional networks
which can actually work on these
high resolutions directly by applying
only the local convolution operation
so these are sequence elements of
whatever form
and every of the one of these sequence
elements exposes a
query vector so the query vector is a
vector that's supposed to
tell uh sort of what it wants to know
about the other sequence elements and
then also each one
exposes a key vector so the key vector
tells a little bit like what's contained
in the in this token
so the way this is routed is that
the query each query is compared to each
key
and then the information is routed
according to which ones have the
largest inner product for example the
next
representation of this token right here
we we need to look at its at its query
and we need to compare it to all the
keys that we find
so in this case only this key right here
matches
so we would expect that um a lot of
the connection between those two is very
strong
ultimately what you're going to do in
here in here you're going to build up a
fully connected
layer right everything's connected to
everything with different strengths
but the strength of the connection is
dynamic the strength of the connection
is determined by the uh
by the attention mechanism rather than
fully
learned okay so
so an mlp would be a fully learned
connection
matrix which is fixed however an
attention matrix is a dynamic
connection matrix in this case
in the cross covariance attention we do
something very similar
but we have to think a bit differently
so now here what we have
is essentially we have vectors
let's represent these token things as uh
vectors and
let's have three no we have five data
points
and they all have four dimensions we'll
leave away
query and key and so on right now so
what what you do
is you don't watch the tokens as a
sequence
however you watch the channels as the
sequence so this here is now one element
this is one element this is one element
and this is one element
so you'd have to somehow trans can i
rotate this i cannot
yeah i cannot rotate it you just
imagine in your mind this rotated now
each channel
exposes a query and then each channel
exposes a key
and now the information is routed not
between uh sequences of not between
from token to token but from channel to
channel
so essentially you look across the
entire
uh sequence in the first channel
and you decide okay what kind of
information is in this
first feature across the entire sequence
and you can
see kind of how that makes sense so with
the self-attention you can see that
you know a token in a in a picture it
might be an
eye so a patch a patch might contain a
part of an
eye right and then another patch might
contain a part of a
mouth right here okay there's a tooth
and uh it would be
important if these two things could
communicate with each other
because that would give a hint that
there might be a face
in the image in this framing
um we look across we look across all
of the things right and maybe the first
channel
is responsible for recognizing eye like
structures anywhere in the image right
across all the patches
so this could be like the channel that
is kind of like i think there's an
eye somewhere and then this here could
be the channel that says i think there's
like
a mouth uh somewhere
in the image and you can also see it's
valuable if those two
things communicate it comes away from
this localization aspect
and more towards communicating across
the entire sequence what kind of
features there
are now it's not directly the channels
that expose
this of course so if you think it's also
not
you know directly the tokens that are
compared here
so if you think of your data matrix
x as a big matrix and this big matrix
has is n by d
somehow uh not somehow but
exactly so you have n data points and
every data point has an embedding of
size d maybe d
is four here so we have n vectors each
has
four entries what you would do in the
self attention is you would transpose
this
like so and what you would obtain
would be a matrix of size d by d
but not until in between
you multiplied with sorry
you multiplied with the keys and the
value matrices
so the way the self-attention formula
works
is that you first multiply x by
a they have the formula somewhere here
on the comparison so what you do
is if this is x you multiply this
by a matrix that is learned that gives
you the queries
and then you multiply x also
with the you multiply
x with the matrix that is supposed to
give you the keys
and then you transpose this and then
that is
your self attention so it becomes
something like x
w q w k transposed
x transposed so you can see the
how the information flows is modulated
by these learned parameters here and
that gives you the self attention matrix
so essentially you will have a
transformation
matrix right here let's say that's d
by d for simplicity and that is
you don't want to compare the tokens
directly but you want to compare sort of
a function
of the tokens so we have that then you
have the
key weight matrix
which is also d by d and then you have
this thing right here so you can see
that gives you an
n by n matrix ultimately which tells you
how much every single data point is
connected or attending to how
to which other data point okay
so this is this routing table
we saw up here ultimately this matrix
right here
is this matrix right here and that's how
it comes to be
so what do you do with this matrix
famously right you take this
you do the soft max of your x w
w x like this
and you multiply it by the so-called
values and the values are nothing else
then again you multiply some sort of
weight matrix
um to multiply some sort of weight
matrix
with your data
so do i have this correctly
right here um yeah i guess
so you have this and you multiply
this you have the soft max of this you
multiply
your again your data matrix
by some sort of other function
but essentially this here are the values
and you decide how to mix the values
of each of the tokens to get the next
tokens so from the point of view
of one token in the output layer
you decide how should i aggregate across
the values of the input layer
that's what the attention gives you now
if we look at cross
attention sorry if you knew all this but
it's now we contrast this with cross
attention
so what we do in cross attention is we
again have our data matrix
like so but
what we do is we again we multiply
um by queries and keys by these matrices
but now we do it differently we do it
so first now i've i need to replace this
up here so
why is it green
orange wow i didn't know you could do
that this is freaky
all right i'm done now thanks so
we again multiply this here but we
multiply by the other thing from the
left
like this so it's the same data the same
matrices
but now they are multiplied in a
different order
which means that as you can see right
here this is no longer the
matrix of inner products being computed
here
this is in fact i guess the matrix of
outer products
and coincidentally the matrix of outer
products is probably
smaller than the matrix of inner
products because
the dimensionality here
d is smaller i have made
yes okay so you can see here this is d
by d this is d by
n this is n by d and then this is d
by d so the resulting matrix is going to
be
a d by d matrix not an n by n matrix
which means that right here we aggregate
across the sequence okay so the
information of where
things are is in the sequence gets lost
and is aggregated across
and this here directly this here is the
if this were centered it's the
covariance matrix but i think they call
it the
cross covariance matrix or
yeah because it's not centered but
essentially it is
the covariance matrix of the
mini batch you have right here not of
the mini batch sorry
it's the covariance matrix across the
tokens in a single data point
so this matrix here essentially tells
you
how you need to aggregate the channels
for in order to go to the next layer so
this again
is multiplied by the
values and as we said before the values
are just a linear function
but again here this is now multiplied
from ah this is now multiplied from the
left and not from the right so
again we have our data right here
and we have our this by the way
i didn't label it before this is v vw
sorry wv another learned function that
gives you the values
okay so this here
are the values and
this here tells you how you how one
channel
attends to the other so every token
here goes through this process
independently
okay so for every talk it's essentially
every token by
itself goes now through this process of
aggregating
features uh from the other channels in
the token
so very much this is like a one by one
convolution
okay with uh this here being the
convolutional kernel
so usually i guess the convolutional
kernel is represented differently
because you also want to represent it in
in space but essentially
this tells you how you aggregate
information across
channels in this one single token so
every single token
goes through this map that is first of
all the learned map but then the
dynamically constructed map
so this is very much a dynamic one by
one
convolution where the convolutional
kernel
is dependent on the entire
sequence okay but there is no
information
mixing there is no information sharing
across
tokens anywhere here except implicitly
because of course the weights in this
kernel are dependent
on the entire sequence up here but
not explicitly so once we have the
kernel once we have the
how we aggregate across the channels
every token
only aggregates across its own
channels okay so the information doesn't
get spread
across the across the image or whatnot
across the sequence
like in the self attention and that is
that's why i'm saying i'm not even sure
this is a transformer
because so far it's just a dynamic one
by one convolution
the second layer sorry the third layer
here
is a feed forward network and this is
exactly the same
as this right here so the except
in the feed forward network again every
token goes by itself
and reconfigures itself according to
some uh
channel mutation according to some one
by one convolution
however uh the feed forward network is a
learned uh con a learned transformation
and not a dynamic one so the xca
transformation is a dynamically
so it's learned but the dynamic
production is learned and the feed
forward network is just
learned directly with a direct weight
matrix
so essentially these are two feet
forward layers here
except one is dynamic and then the only
other thing they have here
is this local patch interaction
and what is this this is essentially a
convolution
it not essentially it is exactly a
so if you think of this
of this sequence of tokens
the first step is we aggregate across
all the tokens
right then we come up with a
transformation
and then every token goes through this
by itself okay so that's the
that's the first layer we just discussed
then there is a convolution
and the convolution is just a yeah a
local patch interaction they call it but
it's essentially a convolution
so it's a convolutional kernel that
slides across the sequence and
um yeah gives you
sort of the next sequence so for example
this token right here it it
will be able so its convolutional kernel
reaches
this this and this one okay and this is
not
an attention mechanism this is just a
classic convolutional kernel
and it is even depth separated so this
goes only
within the same feature channel
so if you think again of our data matrix
here with the featured channels
um the convolutional kernel would be
something like aggregating over
this and just you just slide it
everywhere you slide it
so it's depth wise separable
and you slide it across the image
right here so the the good thing here is
that
this gives you the interaction between
tokens even if only local
but it doesn't add a lot to the
parameters because
if it's depth wise separable right it's
very few parameters and actually also
very few
uh there's not much compute and memory
overhead
but again this is a convolution so the
first step is a convolution
the second step is a convolution and
like an explicit convolution and the
third step the feed-forward one
again is kind of like a convolution so
here
you have a box much like here except you
don't come up with the box dynamically
you simply
learn the box and then every token goes
by itself
through the box okay independent of all
the other tokens
and that's how you get the next layer so
this is it
it's a dynamic convolution followed by a
real convolution followed by
a so it's a dynamic one by one
convolution followed by a real
depth-wise separable but not one by one
bigger convolution
actual convolution and then it it's
followed by
a feed forward layer which again is kind
of like a one by one
convolution so that's the
idea behind this now
is it good or bad or you know
independent of whether this should be
called a transformer
because you know if i think of a
transformer
i i do think of an attention mechanism
and the core
of the attention mechanism is this
information routing between
elements of the sequence right just
because
you transpose it and call it attention
doesn't i mean it's kind of like an
attention mechanism in that it contains
a soft max
and it contains like keys and queries
um but yeah then
just because then you call it attention
and then that becomes a transformer
i'm not super sure uh
yeah maybe you know are we now calling
everything that
has dynamic weights a transformer
i don't know i guess we have to come to
terms with the
the terminology right here of this
however
this appears to work quite well
so um here they say these are the
contributions right here so they include
include cross covariance attention it
includes a
it provides a transposed alternative to
conventional self-attention
instead of channels instead of tokens
it tends to fix number of channels
irrespective of the number of tokens
okay there are more robust to changes in
image resolution which is also a good
thing
right uh so you can do variable size
images
and they say for image classification we
demonstrate that our models are on par
with state-of-the-art vision
transformers
from what for using multiple model sizes
they reach good accuracy on imagenet
they can do dense prediction tasks and
they can do self-supervised
learning using something like dino
and i've made a video about dyno and if
you so if you use the back the excite
backbone with dyno
uh it works apparently pretty pretty
well
so cool this raises a number of
questions
right so it raises kind of more
let's say more theoretical question to
explain what's
going on in here because there is an
intrinsic connection between the two
kinds of attention right they're not
just
random and look the same but there is
actually discussion in the paper right
here
about the relationship between gram and
covariance matrices
here so you can transform one into the
other
other and also the the eigen spectrums
are related not only related but
actually equivalent so they say the
non-zero part
of the eigen spectrum of the gram and
covariance matrix are equivalent
and the eigenvectors can be computed in
terms of each other
so there's an intrinsic connection
between the two things even though
conceptually
they're very very different and i think
to
to go ahead and really kind of explain
which one is good in which situations
why we do what and so on is there even a
difference
that is um still to be seen
the second thing is that if this
actually really works as they advertise
and
you know with recognitions of things
like mlp mixer and so on
it seems like it's it's not even
important how you do it as long as you
kind of shuffle information around a
little bit
um and then you kind of do feed forward
layers
mixed with shuffling information around
a little bit in some way
and this all appears to be kind of
performing on par with each other
now we have seen a trend to go away from
we got a new state of the art to more
like we perform on par
with uh so you never know how much
you know how much trial and error and
engineering went into this to actually
make it perform on par
with and then lastly
um yeah this is interesting because as
you can see right here
this model can handle for example
different image resolutions
and it does scale linearly
with the image resolution so the the gpu
memory consumption
you can see right here is even better
than something like a resnet
50 right and that's uh that's pretty
pretty impressive though on the
engineering side
there are a number of things that
apparently you have to do
when you do these things so one is like
l2 normalizing
correctly and and without that it breaks
down
temperature scaling is another thing
so they have a learned temperature
parameter right here
as you can see without which the
performance degrades a little bit
too and there are there's another
thing this block diagonal cross
covariance tension
so not even they don't even attend from
all
channels to all channels so this matrix
i've shown you before
they actually do this block diagonally
so only like the first two channels can
attend to each other and the last two
channels can attend to each other
they compare this to something like
group normalization
that also has success only normalizing
groups of channels together
so it seems like to me this is my
opinion
it seems like this is much more a
a a better evolution on the uh
on convnets than it is anything
much related to transformers
um so because
also the same kind of things help right
here
uh and yeah making it more local gives
you better performance and so
on uh the fact that there's no in for no
long-range information exchanged
it really seems like an evolution on the
on the convnet so i'm
not really sure what to think of this
other than that
i would love to see this kind of
architecture on
other tasks such as language because
again it being essentially a convnet
also makes it really astute to working
on images here you can see by the way
the attention maps of the classification
layer
which look super duper clean
i guess um so they say heads are
sensitive to similar pictures within the
same or across
images yeah so i would be interested to
see this in
other tasks than than images um
to really see its let's say it's
transformer like
uh properties though i'm not
yeah maybe we can start uh a hashtag
leave transformers alone or something i
don't know we will have to all decide
what a transformer really is
um in terms of performance of course uh
these models they perform
uh fairly well as you can see right here
though there are some trade-offs you can
see right here in
in terms of um in terms of
number of parameters if you compare them
to models of the similar size parameters
these large ones right here they do
often
have more more flops
as you can as you can see right here
though
you can also modify this you can modify
the resolution and they exist in
smaller versions which means larger
patches
sometimes the performance is better
by a little bit so here you can see it
like
it outperforms a little bit i think um
it's a good thing that people say more
like we perform on par with
than touting the point one
uh better performance as kind of
state-of-the-art in their sub
classification
so you also see self-supervised learning
it performs pretty
pretty decently and down there you can
also see
i think they don't have pictures so
there's
object detection instant segmentation
and
so on they do ablation studies
where they figure out that for example
um
removing this xca layer drops their
performance
significantly so this really seems to be
the key ingredient to this even though
it's it's kind of
just quote unquote a dynamic one by one
convolution
but this seems to be the the key
ingredient the workhorse
also this local patch interaction like
the actual convolution
it drops the accuracy but not by that
much
uh but not by as much as removing the
cross the cross covariance attention
layer and you can see that without the
l2 normalization
it just completely fails which you know
is
interesting that so
yeah maybe as a lesson for future
architectures if you're looking to build
a new architecture and you see it just
fails uh probably one
out of uh 200 current tricks that we
know
might make it converge and actually
perform better
than other models so who knows
who knows okay so this model
it looks like yeah it looks like a a
good
thing to try my last criticism here
is that they always use um patches
so at the beginning they tout
oh what we do is we do um
you know we can we can we we don't
depend on the sequence length this
quadratic complexity
yada yada yada so on uh you know we say
right here high resolution images are
prohibitive
yet they still use patches and
i get the idea behind using image
patches
but it seems like if you are able to
process
the full resolution images then
the the lowest patch size why should it
be eight by eight i think
here i think the lowest patch size they
have is eight by eight if i'm not
mistaken
yeah so this here it means i think 24
layers
patches of size eight like
isn't it possible now that we have the
fully like linear complexity in the
number of tokens
to actually go full resolution on these
things
though maybe maybe they did
and i just didn't see that in here
but it seems this usage of patches
themselves
is a bit questionable if you have a
model that is
able to go too high resolutions
or maybe they just want to put their
parameters somewhere else
entirely possible all right so i invite
you to check out this
paper and check out the experimental
results if you're interested
in that it's all fairly fairly well
documented there is a
long appendix that details even more
things and more experimental results
there is pseudo code pytorch style
and yeah there is
uh even some some more queries and
key visualizations okay
so i yeah invite you to check it out
thanks
for listening if you like content like
this
don't hesitate to share it out and i'll
see you next time
bye bye